well it's happening Republican lies
about Obamacare are finally catching up
with them and it is all blowing up in
their faces
since election day it's become so much
more clear that the same Republicans who
for years and years and years under
President Obama would blindly vote to
repeal Obamacare didn't matter because
it wasn't going to get repealed they ran
their campaign against Obamacare based
on lies but it didn't matter because
under Obama it wasn't getting repealed
they ran a campaign against Obamacare
with no alternatives to replace it or
with alternatives that wouldn't work but
it didn't matter because Obamacare was
staying under Obama and now predictably
Pat there's a problem right Republicans
tried to repeal Obamacare something like
60 times and CBS estimated that for each
time it cost the taxpayers 1.5 million
dollars
yep they knew Obama was never going to
repeal his own piece of signature
legislation of court they only did it so
they could go back to their constituents
and brag about it but I think they
realize now it's a lot harder to
actually get legislation passed than it
is to obstruct there's a big problem now
that's one aspect of it and if it turns
out as I've told you people like most of
the provisions of Obamacare other than
the mandate aspect of it and people will
notice if you change the provisions that
they like you can't keep the provisions
they like though without a way to pay
for it affordably like the mandate the
taxes on the very rich the Medicaid
expansion reimbursement you can't
quietly eliminate health care for
millions of people without people
noticing and as a Matthew Iglesias piece
on box points out people will notice if
their deductibles go way up or their
premiums skyrocket doctors and hospitals
and health care providers will notice if
patients all of a sudden don't have
money for treatment it was easy to
oppose Obama care for over six years
based on unhinged lies it wasn't that
difficult to win an election on the idea
of repeal and replace when you actually
didn't have to do anything yet they
might even be able to pass some version
of their bill based on the lies that it
will work but at some point there
we'll be consequences if people lose
care or costs explode this is why the
replacement looks more and more like
what we have except without a real plan
to pay for it there's a PR aspect here
as well the less that the replacement to
Obamacare changes anything in terms of
what's sort of publicly facing it will
be less obvious to the trumpet and to
Republican voters that Republicans will
have broken a promise to repeal and
replace and this is super important we
actually should be calling this republic
hair or GOP care for now not Trump care
calling it Trump care now when right now
it's still just a Republican plan will
actually allow Republicans to avoid
consequences electoral II if it fails by
just saying hey after all this is Trump
care you've all been calling it Trump
care from the beginning I misspoke
yesterday pattern was calling it Trump
care I think for the time being from a
optics perspective we should be
referring to this as Republic hair
because that's really what it is so far
especially cuz Trump doesn't seem like
he has anything to do with this I mean
Obama was was like on the process from
the very beginning yeah when he was
trying to pass the Affordable Care Act
Trump has just delegated this
responsibility off to the Republicans in
Congress and I'm going to talk about
that later in the show because that's
another really important aspect of
what's going on there's also though like
much of what's going on right now with
the discussions around the Trump
administration and Republican policies a
sort of missing the forest for the trees
aspect we are understandably talking
about the minutiae and the details of
Obamacare the ACA the aah a etc but you
can't lose sight of the fact that the
entire system is fundamentally immoral
and one that no other country at our
level of development has this for-profit
insurance system the real conversation
should be let's go to single-payer
let's nationalize health care let's
remove the profit motive for people's
health that's not where we are so this
is the conversation and I talked about
this with the pipeline stuff remember
Trump's lie that Keystone XL would be
made with us feel and Trump lied about
that we actually figured out actually
that's not true
the pipeline if it's made is not going
to be made with us feel and we explained
all of the reasons why fundamentally
though there should be no pipelines
right that's the tie level message the
top level message here is this entire
concept of how we connect healthcare to
employment and for-profit companies that
is completely bogus and corrupt we have
to talk about the details but we
shouldn't miss the forest for the trees
we have to make the assertion that we
disagree with the big picture but within
the framework that they're going to
propose yeah we can make disagreements
inside of that as well
that's absolutely right and we need to
do it with the pipeline we need to do
with healthcare we need to do it with
every issue where it is warranted